when you write a great song like who
will save your soul um when you write a
song like that it comes out of
your misery in a way so like you're not
miserable anymore like it's almost
i never wrote miserable you know i wrote
a whole saver song when i was 16. i was
where were you at hoboing well it's
interesting you know when i was 16 i got
a scholarship to a very prestigious fine
arts school
the money i lacked i did a fundraiser in
my hometown and they helped raise the
money to send me to school
which is remarkable how nice is that
amazing for spring break you had to
leave campus and i couldn't afford
i didn't know you had to buy books i was
so ignorant i just showed up with the
tuition
but that's how i was period nobody
prepared you yeah
yeah yeah you have these two weeks
spring break and and i had nowhere to go
with no money
and so i thought it was amazing to me
how here in the states all the states
are so close together in a matter of
hours you can be in a whole new state
right and so i thought i'd hobo by train
across the country to san diego and i'd
hitchhike from tijuana to cabo and then
take a ferry to the mainland side of
mexico and then isn't it
sounds incredibly dangerous i got on the
greyhound from traverse city to detroit
i still spent the night in the detroit
city bus station so that's a miracle in
itself
and then got a on a train and i made it
to chicago
and that was my first stop and my plan
was to street sing except i didn't know
anybody's music i had just learned
chords i learned a minor c g and d right
and uh
i just started making up lyrics my dad
had taught me to improvise as a kid and
just improvise about what was happening
and so i made up lyrics about people
walking by and
it's my first time in a city my first
time seeing skyscrapers my first time
seeing pop culture my first time i come
from a rural community it's very
grounded very down to earth and there
wasn't this worship of
things television and things and and
wanting to be other people and
and so that's you know people living
their lives for you on tv they wish they
were better than you and you agree
right and just about wealth and power
and she loves somebody of hearing their
will and
so you start freestyling right on the uh
on the street and that's where who who
will save your soul came from yeah i
wrote it that whole trip so i'd take my
change to the office window the ticket
station of amtrak and they'd give me
a ticket for maybe 20 miles down the
road or something
and i'd get out and i made it it's about
three days to san diego and then i
hitchhiked
um from tijuana down to cabo and then
took a ferry to the mainland side i took
trains all through the copper canyons
the coprades
and i just kept writing the song and it
got longer and longer and longer and
that ended up becoming
wholesaver soul who will save yourself
how much of it do you want as much as
you can handle
people on tv
there's nothing for free another big
don't go to hell well another doctor's
bill of lawyers bill another cute cheap
thrill you know you love them if you put
them in your will
[Music]
after all
[Music]
oh
[Music]
another day another dollar another war
another tower went up
where the homeless had their homes so we
pray to as many different
gods as there are flowers but we call
religion
our friend we're so worried about
us saving our souls afraid that god will
take his toll that we forget to begin
but who is
[Music]
after all those lies
if you won't save
got social security but that won't pay
your bills
there's addictions to feed and there are
mouths to
pay so you're bargaining with the devil
so you're okay today
say that you love them take their money
and grow
and say it's been swell sweetheart but
it was
just one of those things those strings
those flings you gotta cut so get out on
the streets girls and
bust your butts
let's say your soul
[Music]
and who save your soul
if you won't save your own
[Music]
way
beautiful wow
oh i will save your soldier
you